it feels so good to be making a Dark
Souls 3 video with actual footage so
about a month ago I put out a video
talking in depth about everything I had
learned from playing the gamescom demo
of Dark Souls 3 I talked about how the
game felt the bosses the enemies the
webinars and now we finally have footage
of that demo 4 minutes of it in fact
plus new info on magic covenants
multiplayer new game+ and more so let's
dive into it so if this is your first
time seeing Dark Souls 3 gameplay the
first thing you'll probably notice is
that a lot of these animations look
really similar to those in Dark Souls 1
and they are really similar in a
sentence what I've been saying lately is
that it feels like the mechanics and the
pacing of Dark Souls 1 but with the
polish and the fluidity of blood-borne
and Miyazaki confirms as much in an
interview he says that blood-borne
influenced a lot of the tuning and
adjustments to Dark Souls 3
however blood-borne doesn't have that
same role-playing element and the
customization of souls so he says that
the team will be focusing on those
things for Dark Souls 3 but let's talk a
little bit about the new features in
this demo it bears mentioning that this
demo that you're seeing here is an
updated version from one month ago there
are some new features we can talk about
like the mana bar magic and a cleric
style character who's featured towards
the end Dark Souls 3 still has a lot of
development to go before its release
date in April so bear that in mind but
by now you've probably noticed that
there's a mana bar in the top left
just like in Demon Souls in previous
demos this mana bar was a point system
and these points were consumed whenever
you used a weapon art ability now it's a
mana bar and both magic and weapon art
attacks will consume it if you don't
know what weapon arts are let me quickly
explain a weapon art is activated when
you press l2 and it opens up a couple of
new moves for your use depending on the
weapon that you're using so the short
swords weapon art is a stance 12 and art
you hold l2 and your character goes into
this stance from here you can press r1
to do a special uppercut
break attack or you can press r2 to do a
charging stab attack the greatswords
weapon art is a combo weapon art you
press l2 and your character slams the
sword down vertically but from there you
can press r2 to do a huge uppercut that
launches the enemy into the air
there are also some webinars that simply
activate when you press l2 for example
the scimitar does a spin attack and the
battle ax does a battle cry and there's
also the webinar for this mace that's
shown towards the end of this clip
though we can't tell what's happening
here from this short clip it's possible
that this webinar made his next attack
do more damage but it's also possible
that he didn't combo it properly I might
be able to try this out next time I get
my hands on the game if you have a
weapon art shield
designated by this little sword symbol
here you can use a weapon art with l2
with the shield still equipped if you
have a parry shield which is designated
by this symbol
you simply parry when you press l2 and
if you to hand your weapon you can use a
weapon art regardless of what she'll do
you have equipped so that mana bar in
the top left isn't just for casting
spells it's used for melee combat as
well mana doesn't appear to replenish
overtime but you can replenish it with a
new type of Estus flask which I believe
is called an ash Estus flask it's
visible in the bottom left the little
blue flask there so now when you're
going through a level you have to
sparingly use your Estus flask for
health and your ash Estus flask for mana
so it's another layer on top of a system
that was already a good system to begin
with so I can't imagine this being a bad
thing but let's move on to actual spells
as far as I know we know of six spells
so far there's soul arrow soul great
sword and soul dart which you can see
here for miracles there's lightning
spear a healing spell and sacred oath
which increases your attack and defense
for a short while obviously there'll be
more spells in fact in an interview with
game informer Miyazaki has stated that
players will have more criteria to
accurately choose the types of spells
that will fit your tactics or your
strategies and while the spells that
we've seen here are pretty standard bear
in mind we haven't heard
about what a weapon art for magic does
so I assume it's some way of deepening
the magic system let's move on to some
of the information revealed by a Game
Informer first up is covenants Miyazaki
mentions that he wants covenants to be
easier to understand on this topic he
says that covenants have always had
separate rules depending on each of the
covenants but this time we're thinking
of maintaining a common rule across the
covenants regarding invasions and
summoning so for example I take this
quote to mean that there could be one
covenant item for everybody regardless
of your covenant but the covenant you're
in determines what this item does like
an invasion item that changes the type
of enemy you invade based on your
covenant next is something that I'm
really excited about for me one of the
best things about a Souls game is that
thrill of being invaded and of invading
somebody else and it looks like these
systems are going to be simplified which
means that these systems are going to
become more popular Miyazaki states that
invasions and summoning will no longer
be locked behind consumable items which
naturally will help invasions become
more plentiful he also states that soul
memory is being removed which is good
and they're also aiming for six-person
multiplayer functionality let's quickly
talk about fast travel players will now
be able to fast travel from the very
beginning of the game since Miyazaki
apparently liked the convenience that
brought to Dark Souls 2
there has been no information on the
room and mechanic where you can create
your own bonfire via sacrifice so we'll
have to wait and see if that changes the
pacing of the game if it does end up
existing but moving on remember the soul
vessel from Dark Souls 2 it was an item
that allowed you to Reese Peschel eyes
your character and put your soul level
points in different categories
apparently it's returning for Dark Souls
3 in some form next is New Game+ one of
the best things about Dark Souls 2 was
new game+ and the fact that it offered
new enemies and new enemy placements and
new experiences game informer reveals
that this system will be returning
however bonfire ascetics that allow you
to
and an area to New Game+ to farm certain
enemies and face certain bosses again
will not be returning and next is
durability miyazaki mentions that he's
still tuning the balance on durability
and he wants weapons to break more
slowly than in Dark Souls 2 but faster
than in Dark Souls 1 so summer in the
middle and finally hidden walls are
returning and unlike in Dark Souls 2 you
have to actually hit the hidden wall to
unveil it and before you go I want to
let you know one more thing I'm going to
be playing the TGS demo tomorrow or
maybe today by the time this video is
released and I'm definitely going to
learn more about the demo so I'll be
putting this new information in the top
line of the description and also on
Twitter so if you're watching this on
the day it came out then follow me on
Twitter so you don't have to miss
anything but if you're not following
it's probably just in the first line of
the description I don't anticipate that
I'll be able to learn too much more from
playing the updated demo but I'll
definitely learn more about weapons and
a couple of new spells so that'll be
cool
but thanks for watching guys I got to
say I'm really excited for Dark Souls 3
just because it'll bring the community
back together which is a nice thing and
it's sounding pretty good so far so let
me know what you think in the comments I
still read them all so don't leave that
box empty and yeah I'll see you guys in
the next one